can't blame the executives job is to
bring along the legislature I don't use
the word manage because they have their
own good yeah third of the government if
you will a power but it is the
executives job to explain to the
legislators why his or her policies of
the right one and bring them along you
don't go and do a poll asked the public
what they want and then try to take them
there that's leadership from the back
you're elected to go and to say this is
what I'm going to do and convince people
to come along with you and have the
horses to get us all but does it not
disappoint you given what populist
opinion is there are qualified talented
people who could be going into
government and they can't get confirmed
into those positions because of this
bifurcation okay but you know that
that's the executives job to get
Congress to come together you trade you
bribe you threaten you cajole you do all
these sorts of things the same ways you
run your kids you say to your kid clean
your room or you don't get your
allowance you say to you kid you do your
homework for you can't play Angry Birds
you say to your kid you're doing a great
job and let's just do more of it I'll
help you and all work together people
interact on lots of different ways and
it's the executives job to do that with
Congress as well so I'm a believer that
this cut our Congress has been fractured
for the last 239 years has always been
very extreme left very extreme right
they've these parties have changed their
views and their constituency from one
side to the other we forget history so
quickly it changes but this still there
and that's what an executive should do
when you're looking at a presidential
candidate what you should do is figure
out who will be able to do the blocking
and tackling and attract good people
because that person is not going to make
all the decisions and if that person
does try to make all the decisions then
you really have a problem